hello guys and welcome to another video
now before we get into this video there
is going to be spoilers for spider-man
no way home so if you haven't seen the
movie already then please click off this
video with that out of the way let's get
into the video now we finally have some
more information regarding andrew
garfield spider-man in no way home so
let's get into it by december 2020 toby
and andrew were both secretly signed on
to the project but had yet to receive
any script pages mckenna and summers
hunkered down before christmas to get
the pages to toby and andrew the writers
were relieved to find that actors not
only liked what they read but were also
enthusiastic partners in developing
their characters further they had
thoughts and it was really interesting
and helpful to see their thoughts no one
knows the characters as well or gives as
much thought to the character as someone
who has to then embody and sell it it
definitely shaped what we did garfield
who starred in two amazing spider-man
films embraced exploring the dark path
as peter parker went down after the
death of gwen stacy he also latched on
to the notion that his version of peter
was the middle brother they had great
ideas that really elevated everything we
were going for and added layers and an
arc and we really actually started
honing into the idea that these guys
were really helping tom's peter on his
journey to becoming who he ends up
becoming there's a crucial moral moment
that they helped get him through the
climax of the movie so much of that was
brought by toby and andrew's ideas and
shaping of what they thought their
characters could bring to this story the
last time you saw andrew garfield it was
the death of gwen and that must have
sent him down a dark spiral that maybe
he never got out of we don't know
because there wasn't a third movie that
we saw where did he go maybe a really
dark place we wanted to be true to the
characters in those movies really having
conversations about specifying where
they are without giving away too much
andrew garfield really loved the idea
that he's still tortured over what
happened the amazing spider-man 2 and
where they left him and how they could
bring that to tom we can empathize with
you we do know what you're going through
if anyone in the world knows what you're
going through it's us but also we can be
beacons we thought it was cool that
andrews peter was still in that mindset
of that darkness andrew really leaned
into the lonely middle brother that's
one of the things we started saying he
is the middle brother that's why it's so
great when andrew says god i always
wanted to have brothers while simplistic
it's a great paradigm for the fear of
them coming together and wanted to feel
like it's not just doppelgangers they're
different they're not the same person so
what i really love from this interview
is that andrew garfield he really wants
to see the character involved but from a
state which is um very consistent with
his character from an amazing spider-man
2 so he really liked the idea that his
character is still affected by the
darkness that he experienced from losing
gwen stacy in the second amazing
spider-man and how that has affected him
what he has learned by that and how he
can bring that lesson to help tom
holland spider-man another great thing
that we can take from this interview is
that the writers have no way home and
the actors of spider-man have really
tried hard to um make the spider-man all
feel different feel like different
people and not just the same person and
i think they did a really great job of
that all for spider-man and no way home
feel like they have their own unique
personality i honestly want to see more
of andrew garfield spider-man i know
there's a lot of buzz going around of
make their maze and spider-man in three
and i'm all for it i think he deserves a
third film i feel like his trilogy needs
to be completed and there are rumors
that it's happening so let's hope it's
true anyway with that out of the way
that's pretty much it for this video
guys so tell me in the comments section
below on what you thought of andrew
garfield's
in their way home did you like his
performance do you want to see the
amazing spider-man 3 let me know also
don't forget to like and subscribe and
to turn notifications on to show your
support thanks for watching guys